انا من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد الياس حنا برغم ان
الاوكرانيون ان الاوكرانيين يقولون ان ما
يجري في بيلجرود انما هو عمله
الوطنيين الروس المعارضين لبوتين لكن اصبح
فيها هجمات كثيره الان لماذا تفتح هذه
الجبهه
زين العابدين في بدايه الحرب ايضا خلال
معركه خركاف كانت ايضا هي هدفا للقوات
الاوكرانيه يعني نتذكر انها ضربت مخزن
للوقود كبير جدا هي في وقت من الاوقات
كانت المحطه الخلفيه الاساسيه لللوجستيه
التي تربط بالجروت بالداخل وباتجاه ازيوم
والى المناطق باتجاهك في ذلك الوقت اليوم
فتح الجبهات من خلال هذه المجموعات هي
القدره على النكران يعني من قوات
الاوكرانيه ولكن لا يمكن نقرانها لانها
تحصل على ارض اوكرانيه الهدف منها هو
اظهار صوره الضعف لدى الرئيس بوتين
والجيش وبالتالي نقل الحرب الى الارض
الروسيه اثنين وهنا الامر وتثبيت او سحب
اي احتياط عسكري من مكان ما معد للهجوم
العكسي الاوكراني لتثبيته في مكان ما على
ان يكون هناك تشتيت للقوات الروسيه على
الحدود مع اوكرانيا
ايضا الولايات المتحده حرصت على ان تقول
بعد ما يجري في انها لا تؤيد ولا تدعم
الاوكرانيين في اي هجوم على الاراضي
الروسيه وهنا المقصود لكن القرم ليست لا
تدخل في ضمن هذا التصنيف
القرم حسب القانون الدولي وحسب العقل
الامريكي انها ضمت بالعام 2014 عن غير حق
وفي ذلك الوقت نتذكر زين ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وحتى الاتحاد الاوروبي
فرضوا عقوبات على الرئيس بوتين لانه ضم
بالقوه ولكن اليوم هذه هذه
القرن يعني هي مهمه جدا
للقوات الروسيه انها
الخلفيه اللوجستيه وبالتالي من يتابع
التحصينات التي اجرتها القوات الروسيه في
هذه المنطقه تظهر اهميتها وتظهر الخوف من
ان يكون الهجوم فعلا في منطقه ذابروجيا
ميليتو بول وباتجاه الحدود مع شبه جزيره
قرن اذا تحدثنا عن الهجوم المنتظر هجوم
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الذي يقول البعض
انه بدا بالفعل بهذه المناوشات ما الهدف
منه ما الذي يريد ان يحققه على الارض لان
ليس منطقيا ان نتوقع ان يكون السيطره على
كل دنباس على سبيل المثال
التحرير كل ما يحتله الجيش الروسي امر
مستحيل امر صعب ولكنه ليس مستحيل خاصه في
هذا الوقت اليوم السعيد دائم الى تحقيق
هجوم معين يقلب الموازين بطريقه ما تجبر
الافرقه للوصول الى طاوله المفاوضات وهذا
الامر لن يحصل ولن يكون كبير جدا الا اذا
حصل وحسب التحليلات الروسيه ايضا حصل في
منطقه
وبالتالي قطع الجسر البري بين القرم وبين
الدومباس وبالتالي يقسم الجيش الروسي الى
عده اماكن معينه لينسحب وتصبح القوات
الاوكرانيه على الحدود مع شبه جزيره القرم
هذا امر يعتبر جيم تشينجر او نقطه تحول
اساسيه قد تذهب الى مفاوضات قد تذهب الى
وقت نار وبالتالي الانتقال الى مرحله
جديده فيما يتعلق بطائرات الاكس 16 يعني
اذا كان هنالك من يقول انه حتى الدبابات
دبابات وتشالنجر وغيرها لم تصل
فما مدى واقعيه وصول طائرات سته عشر وايضا
بالنسبه لتصريح نائب وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه ان روسيا ستضربها هل روسيا قادره
على ذلك فعلا
بالطبع يعني السلاح الدفاع الجوي الروسي
سلاح متقدم وان تكون هذه الطائرات هدف هذا
امر طبيعي زين لانه هذه الطائرات تعتبر
طائرات عدوها ومن المبدا اسقاطها اذا
استطاع الجيش الروسي اليوم الخلاف على
التدريب روسيه لكن ماذا لو كان في
اوكرانيا
اليوم عندما نتحدث عن اوكرانيا زين هناك
اربعه اقاليم يعتبرها الرئيس بوتين بالعقل
الروسي من خلال مرسوم انها ارض روسيه هذا
الامر يتيح له على الاقل في تحليله الخاص
ولكن اذا لم تحلق فاذا لن يكون هناك اسقاط
لهذا الموضوع فاذا هذه الطائرات العدد
المده اللازمه اللوجستيه ومتى ستاتي هذه
وهل ستكون جزء اساسي من الهجوم المنتظر
لانه بالحد الادنى حسب الجوجل نيوز انه
يستلزم من خلال تقرير لقوات السلاح الجو
الامريكي انه يستلزم اربعه اشهر بعكس ما
يقال انها تستلزم ثمانيه او 12 شهر
العبيد الياس حمض الخبير العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه ضيفنا من بيروت شكرا جزيلا
لك